pour alexeï navalni cela ne fait aucun
doute
vladimir poutine est derrière son
empoisonnement l'homme la firme dans un
entretien au magazine allemand der
spiegel
des accusations qui semble pour
l'instant reposer davantage sur une
intime conviction que sur des preuves
matérielles
j'affirme que poutine est derrière cet
acte je ne vois pas d'autre explication
pas d'autre explication un motif
d'accusation jugé trop léger par les
accusés moscou considère les
déclarations de navalni comme sans
fondement et inacceptable
le kremlin il voit qu'une tentative
d'ingérence dans cette affaire avec
washington
en ligne de mire les agences de
renseignement occidentales travaille
avec lui je peux même dire
spécifiquement que des instructeurs de
la cia travaille en ce moment avec lui
alexeï navalni conteste et réclame cette
fois ci des preuves de sa collaboration
avec les agences de renseignement
occidentales
il annonce également vouloir poursuivre
en justice le porte parole du kremlin
et se dit décidé à rentrer en russie le
plus vite possible
là encore dimitri peskov réagi et
ironise n'importe quel citoyen russe
peut rentrer au pays à tout moment il
n'y a là rien d'héroïque la porte parole
de la diplomatie russe a quant à elle
annoncé que son pays a demandé la
participation de l'organisation
internationale pour l'interdiction des
armes chimiques à l' enquête en
coopération avec les spécialistes russes
en attendant la sphère navalni continue
d'alimenter les pressions
internationales sur moscou des pressions
américaines et européennes notamment le
mois dernier berlin annoncé d'ailleurs
entamé des discussions sur de possibles
sanctions contre la russie